[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radiofrancia internacional
ponemos el foco en Chile un país en
plena ebullición vamos a intentar dar
las claves para entender el rechazo al
plebiscito constitucional me acompañan
en este estudio tres invitados les
presento ya a Mariló Sara de la si eres
catedrática investigadora en el
instituto católico de París bienvenida
Buenos días gracias por su invitación mi
compañera Paula Martínez Infante
periodista independiente bienvenida
Paola por la invitación y Manuel sus
artes doctorando en historia en el
instituto de altos estudios
latinoamericanos bienvenido Manuel
Muchas gracias Gracias también por la
invitación
claves para entender el rechazo al
plebiscito constitucional en Chile hoy
nuestro asunto en Primera Plana
si le rechazó de forma contundente y con
un 62% la nueva constitución el
resultado supone un golpe muy duro para
el gobierno de Gabriel borich que lo
había apostado todo un triunfo del sí y
que ha tenido que remodelar su gobierno
para avanzar hacia un nuevo proceso
Constituyente los chilenos dijeron en el
pasado de forma mayoritaria que querían
romper con la Constitución de pinochet
pero ahora también dicen que no de esta
forma para muchos en Chile fracasó el
maximalismo progresista dando cuenta que
un texto para todos tiene que recoger
una suma mucho más amplia los
convencionales elaboraron una propuesta
que para muchos socialmente fue muy
rápido y quizás demasiado lejos vamos a
intentar analizarlo hoy en el programa
antes Vamos a repasar como siempre
algunas portadas que nos deja la prensa
diario El Mercurio propuesta
constitucional de la convención es
ampliamente rechazada diario Concepción
chile rechazó por amplio margen y ya la
tercera está la misma semana con las
consecuencias gobierno y partidos
acuerdan un nuevo proceso Constituyente
en el congreso iborit cambia de equipo y
modera su gabinete vamos a empezar con
una cuestión para los tres qué
elecciones deja este rechazo Marino para
mí es como una paradoja no se entiende
desde fuera porque con un 68% del pueblo
a favor de la Reforma constitucional se
pasa a un 62 para el rechazo del
proyecto constitucional yo creo que
bueno Muchos analistas han comentado una
sanción hacia el gobierno hacia boliche
y su política otros hablan de
desinformación pero para mí también es
una una lección de democracia es decir
que el pueblo chileno es exigente quiere
una reforma profunda Pero quizás no haya
que ir demasiado rápido en ciertas
temáticas y buscar más consenso y yo
creo también que quizá el texto en ese
ámbito tenga unas flaquezas que que hay
que redefinir delinear mejor
estas temáticas no vamos a tratar de
esos puntos flacos del texto elecciones
Paola Yo pienso que la elección A mi
parecer es que el cambio paradigma tan
radical como lo pretendía justamente
esta Constitución Este pero este
proyecto constitucional tarda en llegar
todavía existía en Chile Esa esa ese
impulso que había dado el estadio social
en octubre esos cambios esas
reivindicaciones sociales que eran muy
fuertes y muy numerosas también que dan
cuenta un descontento una desigualdad
tremenda y que con este proceso
finalmente la legitimación del sistema
político también está en jaque quiere
decir que Ok queremos cambios queremos
la revolución en la calle pero al
momento de establecer qué puntos van a
estar en la mesa para poder discutir ahí
el otro la otra lección es que
Finalmente nos dimos cuenta que hay
muchos votantes chilenos no solamente el
rechazo de la gente que está por la
construcción de pinochet sino que como
bien lo decías tú hay una panoplia de
posibilidades que se abren y la gente
rechaza tanto por el aborto está lo
veremos tal vez en detalle más tarde por
la plurinacionalidad hay diferentes
puntos que provocaron también Esa esa
reticencia a este cambio radical pero
sobre todo lo que yo retengo es que un
proceso de cambio de la Carta Magna No
por nada se llama así necesita todavía
más tiempo y tal vez fue muy precipitado
avanzarse en ese cambio un año después
de una prueba de cambio de Constitución
la velocidad Manuel Sí una gran lección
que nadie yo creo vio venir de esta
manera es Qué pasa cuando la mayoría del
padrón electoral alrededor de un 85% de
los votantes totales del país vota
justamente uno de los grandes mitos que
se ha construido siempre es que siempre
son los más politizados los que votan la
derecha tiene un voto muy duro y siempre
se soñaba un poco con esta idea de del
pueblo participando en la votación y
llegó el momento en que esta idea de
pueblo que la masa de votantes chilenos
votó y el resultado es bastante bastante
increíble en ese sentido Entonces esto
plantea ya muchos desafíos para los
partidos políticos para la comunicación
política también y justamente para lo
que va a ser el proceso Constituyente
que va a venir ahora el proceso
constitucional en todo caso lo podríamos
decir que es irrevocable yo creo que sí
porque hay un consenso en la clase
política salvo unos partidos como la
unión democrática independiente o el
partido republicano de de Cash yo creo
que en general a pesar de las posturas
políticas y hay un consenso para que
siga el proceso Y a partir de ahora
entonces cómo va a evolucionar ese nuevo
proceso Manuel da la impresión en estos
pocos días que estamos volviendo a lo
que era la fórmula de la comisión mixta
en un inicio que era básicamente la idea
de una asamblea o una una asamblea
Constituyente con mitad de electores
fuera de partidos mitad de congresistas
digo esto porque los que están llevando
la negociación Ahora son los partidos en
el congreso Entonces se va a mediar todo
a través de eso uno de los puntos más
fuertes que está dando vuelta ahora en
la negociaciones es no permitir listas
de independientes fuera de partidos por
ejemplo porque daría nuevamente paso a
que un proceso Constituyente se
construyera fuera de los canales de los
partidos y no hubiera esta coordinación
que debería tener entre comillas la
gobernabilidad de un país vamos a
profundizar si les parece en este punto
una vez que hemos expuesto un poco el
escenario general en algunas de las
claves que podrían explicar el triunfo
del rechazo y por qué ha sucedido todo
esto voy a enumerar varias ustedes me
las van analizando como consideren una
que sea utilizado mucho es decir que
este plebiscito ha sido un plebiscito al
gobierno de borich les pregunto esto
incidido no informarse tanto por el
texto en sí
de alguna manera una de las de las
razones que se evocan efectivamente la
gente que votó rechazo es una manera de
descreditar un poco el trabajo los seis
meses del gobierno de Gabriel borich no
olvidemos que él llegó también al poder
con una mayoría que era no tan amplia
tampoco Ah el país está polarizado y
dividido la elección de
llegó también un personaje la extrema
derecha con un alta votación entonces lo
que pasa que insisto de nuevo está esa
idea de que la gente quiere respuestas Y
ya que respuestas inmediatas porque como
lo decían en los eslogan de nuevo
insisto el estadio Social es muy
importante en la manera como se consigue
justamente las esperas y las
expectativas de la gente hoy día y
efectivamente cuando llega Gabriel al
gobierno él plantea que va a haber
reformas bien Por supuesto tributaria en
el sistema de salud etcétera Pero su
gran caballo batalla también es la
reforma la Constitución y vas a una gran
parte de su programa en de forma
constitucional Entonces cuando
finalmente le dicen no es porque también
están de alguna manera no dándole
confianza a lo que queda del gobierno o
diciéndole más bien Mira queremos las
cosas ahora y lo que está los resultados
actuales no sólo suficiente otro punto
tal vez que había que señalar que es el
contexto en la cual está viviendo chile
Hoy día hay un contexto social y
económico que es complicado no solamente
todo se refiere a la Constitución el
proceso Constituyente hay un contexto de
crisis económica de recesión hay un
contexto de crisis migratoria en el
norte del país y un contexto de crisis
también de seguridad en el sur con los
mapuches Entonces todos esos elementos
hacen que de alguna manera han ayudado a
efectivamente dar un rechazo a la
posible a la posición del gobierno de
Gabriel Morocho y en Chile los críticos
consideran que el nuevo texto erosionaba
los contrapoderes con el asunto de la
justicia paralela o la ausencia de toda
Norma sobre partidos políticos y sistema
electoral no sé si Mariló se refería a
estos puntos por ejemplo como de las
flaquezas que antes comentaba Sí también
está el tema de
los derechos que les dejamos a los
pueblos originarios que es un tema muy
importante porque han sido los olvidados
de la independencia podemos decirlo así
pero unas de las cosas que quizá les de
miedo a cierta parte del pueblo es el
riesgo de división Por ejemplo si tienen
sus una autonomía que que no cuaje bien
con las instituciones nacionales por
ejemplo hay otros problemas también que
que pueden ser divertidos como los
papeles de los carabineros y de las
fuerzas armadas que
prerrogativas tienen por ejemplo la
convención Manuel le comenzó su trabajo
en julio de 2021 con altos niveles de
respaldo si no me equivoco pero poco a
poco fue perdiendo ese respaldo
hay que contribuyó ese ese alejamiento
el resultado contribuyó mucho es un poco
la narrativa que se está instalando esta
idea de una de una convención folclórica
uno de los grandes de las grandes
imágenes que se ha tratado de movilizar
es la idea de convencionales votando
desde la ducha por ejemplo o
convencionales disfrazados
da la impresión que la convención cayó
mucho en las lógicas tradicionales de la
política o al menos así lo leyó la gente
sin embargo creo que es una imagen un
poco injusta de lo que fue el trabajo de
la convención sobre todo porque la gran
mayoría de las reglas que afectaban a la
convención Como por ejemplo este plazo
de un año máximo no fueron impuestas por
la convención se le fueron impuestas en
un escenario muy difícil entonces da la
impresión que llegado un momento la
convención no pudo superar la cuesta y
claro entraron también las rencillas
internas y por último un tema que
ejecute muy poco es la responsabilidad
que tuvo a la derecha en el fracaso de
la convención No tanto en su
participación pero justamente en no
haber logrado
elegir sus con propios sus propios
convencionales poner sus temas en el
fondo llegaron muy debilitados y
eligieron un un
enfoque de confrontación las voces más
fuertes que tuvo la derecha en la
convención fueron de extrema derecho
justamente entonces ayudaron un poco a
Si se quiere a pegarle desde adentro a
la convención
ahora el curso que después se estableció
efectivamente en la información que se
da y la información que emanaba de las
discusiones y los temas más álgidos como
insisto el aborto instalarlo la
plurinacionalidad temas que tienen que
ver con la seguridad de la soberanía
efectivamente del país son temas que son
muy ricos y propios a la derecha
entonces esa esa imposición digamos que
del extrema que fue la comisión
prevaleció también como un discurso que
la gente creyó Ah porque también
circularon muchas falsas informaciones
Ah en sentido que nos van a expropiar la
casa que el país se va a transformar
como lo decía anteriormente en un país
plurinacional donde habrá muchos
presidentes entonces hay mucha mucha
desinformación porque yo también creo
que la convención no supo en su momento
dado comunicar correctamente del proceso
que se estaba viviendo al interior de
esas discusiones que no son fáciles
crear una carta una una nueva
constitución un país no es un proceso
fácil es lo que ha determinar la
estructura social económica política de
un país durante mucho largo tiempo a
pinochelo hizo en un momento
encerraban en cuatro muros con siete
personas y ahora había una comisión
participativa paritaria que tenía todas
las garantías y todos los principios
fundadores justamente de una real
democracia finalmente también da cuenta
de un poco de las fallas de esa
democracia no todos están fantástico
como lo guardense algún argumento para
la vuelta pausa en la que vamos a seguir
analizando este rechazo a la nueva
constitución en Chile también los
cambios y cómo ha afectado al gobierno
de Gabriel borich será enseguida que en
Primera Plana hasta ahora
Enlace del cono Sur a Norteamérica de
los Andes a Centroamérica una cita
semanal con los temas más importantes de
los países del continente americano
presentada por los corresponsales de
France 24
enlace en France 24 y France 24.com
la historia de nuestro mundo está en
constante cambio el flujo de información
es cada vez mayor estamos ahí con todos
los temas nos comprometemos con la
verificación desde el terreno en todas
las circunstancias para anticipar el
futuro y entender el presente lo
acompañamos 24 horas 7 días a la semana
France 24 una mirada diferente a la
actualidad Liberty egalité
seguimos en Primera Plana de radio
Francia internacional y de France 24
esta semana analizando el rechazo a la
nueva constitución en chile y las
consecuencias porque Boris por ejemplo
ha tenido que cambiar su gobierno
estamos analizando algunos de los puntos
de de las causas que han permitido este
este rechazo me gustaría hablar también
del contexto que no lo hemos dejado
antes de la pausa porque chile se
enfrenta actualmente podemos decir a una
crisis de inseguridad público al menos
así es percibido se trata de un problema
que ha crecido con los años pero no sé
hasta qué punto afecta directamente a la
ciudadanía que puede votar contra el
gobierno de turno Y eso ha podido pasar
Hasta qué punto esto es un argumento
para el rechazo es un argumento Yo
investigué por supuesto hice un pequeño
una pequeña encuesta alrededor de mucha
gente y desde el contexto y es verdad
que había mucha gente que estaba harta
de ese obtuvimos ah de esa violencia que
se instaló en las calles y que genera
todavía como una suerte de legitimación
en el sentido de que si yo quiero algo
voy a romper un paradero voy a voy tomar
algo voy a hacer barricadas en la calle
Entonces en este clima un poco de
inseguridad la gente Yo pienso que tuvo
miedo también del incertidumbre que
podría provocar ese cambio y no
olvidemos que también hay una no no soy
no quiero entrar en sensacionalismo Pero
hay un sentimiento del chileno medio de
una inseguridad que es latente y que es
creciente Ah como yo lo decía
anteriormente está la crisis en el norte
con la con la inmigración a mucha mucha
no hay que olvidar también que hay mucho
prejuicios también al respecto Ah pero
sí se engloba hay un maximalismo de que
la culpa de los inmigrantes o
maximalismo es decir que la culpa
también la atienden los mapuches en el
sur y la culpa también lo tienes
delincuente en el centro entonces
cuidado con esos argumentos pero es
verdad que también juega un poco en ese
sentimiento un poco inseguridad y el
otro sentimiento que no es menor y creo
que es el más importante y que es
transversal a todo este proceso es la
crisis económica no olvidemos que chile
uno de los países más ilegales
desigualdes Perdón dice iguales de la
médica latina entonces esa la falta
económica genera esta frustración en la
población en la sociedad entera tanto la
clase media como la clase Obrera cierto
de que lo que tienen no les alcanza no
olvidemos el eslogan del estadio social
queremos una vida digna chile despertó
porque ya basta de abusos Entonces en
ese clima digamos de de inseguridad
tanto económica como una inseguridad de
seguridad digamos pública no es menor el
voto también de rechazo preferimos
preferimos tal vez algo que está
consolidado que tiene imperfecciones
pero lo conocemos más vale
conocido que por conocer como dice el
eslogan valoremos el contexto marilor
Esta es la crisis económica y la de la
seguridad hasta que punto han podido
influir en el voto Sí yo creo que hay un
miedo a la polarización en Chile por por
razones históricas también entonces Esto
sí pudo influenciar muchísimo y también
la otra cosa es que yo creo que hay
algunas indicaciones básicas del tu que
quizá no se vean satisfechadas por el
texto de la Constitución y eso pudo ser
una unas de las razones del rechazo Sí
ahí está también la fortaleza del voto
rechazo justamente que es un abanico de
posibilidades la inseguridad por ejemplo
es una una de las razones Sin lugar a
dudas pero también lo podía hacer el fin
del senado podía ser la el miedo al fin
de la propiedad privada ahí se mezcla
con el tema de la desinformación pero en
con respecto a este punto exacto de la
Cómo se llama el problema de seguridad y
la precarización de la vía en general no
hay que olvidar que como todo el mundo
chile viene también saliendo de un
periodo de pandemia que fue muy duro con
restricciones muy duras y con una
sensación general de desamparo de parte
del Estado hacia la ciudadanía entonces
claramente es una olla de presión que
no es responsable Perdona Manuel es no
olvidemos que Piñera estaba al mando En
ese sentido también es simplemente decir
que esta olla de presión de un punto de
vista si uno quiere sacar algo positivo
explotó entre comillas de una forma
democrática en este momento en esta
actuación con una votación de 60 y
cuánto por ciento 65
había amarrado lo podríamos decir el
destino de su gobierno a la suerte en el
plebiscito y ahora parece que debe pagar
los costos no le quedaba otra no había
otra salida
está muy vinculado no el destino de
claro me cuesta creer que en gobierno y
en los partidos de oposición hubiera
habido una confianza ciega en el triunfo
de la prueba yo creo que estaba muy
claro que el rechazo tenía la delantera
porque lo que lo que mostraban las
tendencias Sin embargo a mí me queda la
impresión que tal vez apuntaban algo un
poco más peleado justamente alcanzaron
45% y tal vez tener justamente un
escenario un poco más tenso en el fondo
donde el gobierno pudiera ser que se yo
contra propuestas la derecha no tan
fuerte pero claramente esto lo desarma
un poco desarmó un poco ese plan
Entonces no creo que haya habido
necesariamente necesariamente un error
así decir claramente se puede leer como
un error pero no sé si necesariamente un
un error malicioso de la parte del
gobierno ante el rechazo consecuencias
ha girado hacia el centro remodelando su
gabinete y aproximándose al centro
izquierda tradicional podríamos decir No
sé si podríamos decir que de nuevo
muestra esa plasticidad que caracteriza
al joven líder chileno Mari
una capacidad pragmática no sí sí eso
viene de su recorrido digamos cuando era
presidente de la Federación de
estudiantes de la Universidad de chile
tiene esta plasticidad efectivamente
tiene una manera de entender la política
una vez lo dijo en una entrevista para
para Canal 13 que para él El arte de la
política es entender el punto de vista
adverso para lograr un consenso y crear
un bien común Así que eso fue importante
eso forma parte de su visión política
por eso es muy es muy pragmático yo creo
que sabe sacar las lecciones de sus
errores y varias veces lo dijo dijo yo
voy a hacer errores seguro pero tengo
las manos limpias y el corazón caliente
es lo que dijo también
se ha sumado a esto una agenda de temas
que poseen un acento generacional me
refiero de nuestros tiempos la ecología
el feminismo que galvaniza ciertos
sectores pero no sé si Paola si no ha
ganado un apoyo mayoritario en sino que
está muy sectorizado ese tipo de
pantalla de nuevo Yo pienso que tiene
que ver con temas que de alguna manera
son un objetivo a cierto ideologías
también Ah no olvidemos que por ejemplo
el tema ecológico por decir algo en
madera cuando está instalado la
Constitución qué pasa con el tema de la
ecología es perfecto que tengamos a la
madre tierra la naturaleza en el centro
mismo que nos debemos de cuidarla pero
si eso significa que hay grupos de
extractivistas que van a estar en juego
su economía su actividad en el país
pienso en las mineras pienso en las
forestales en el sur obviamente sus
privilegios no van a querer perderlos
entonces ahí un punto donde se juega la
digamos la naiffet de alguna manera o
esos sueños de un mundo mejor con las
intereses económicos el tema del
feminismo también el feminismo no
olvidemos que las mujeres han sido
determinantes en todos los procesos y no
desde solamente el estadio social antes
también de 2017 que empezó el movimiento
feminista en Chile con fuerza a
reivindicar los abusos las violencias
etcétera y que fue durante todo el
proceso del exterior social un una lucha
absoluta por reivindicar los derechos
por romper justamente con con el
patriarcado que es un feo absoluto
también de América Latina no solamente
en chile y poner el tema de la paridad
en el centro del país eso también genera
conflicto porque tiene que ver con un
conservadurismo que es un poco
subterráneo que tal vez no se conoce Tan
tanto en Chile que hablaba estuvo en el
delante hacia un instante sobre este
electorado que apareció con el voto
obligatorio tal vez ese electorado de
Voto obligatorio no tiene ni unas ganas
de que se hable de diversidad sexual de
aborto de nuevo de paridad en el estado
incluso decía mucha gente en las razones
decía yo no voy a votar porque sea una
mujer un hombre yo no estoy no me
interesa mucho Esa paridad voy a votar
por el más mejor como dicen en Chile
cierto Entonces es verdad que esos temas
que son temas centrales hay mucha
ideología detrás que si uno las pone en
la mesa genera porque hay intereses
económicos que están en juego y la
iglesia católica si viene en Chile ha
perdido un poco de de fuerza el tema de
la moral y de lo que tiene que hacer la
ciudadanía y de cómo la familia Puede
ser también tocada por este tipo de
temas generan genera problemáticas
entonces también son razones por las
cuales ciertos sectores Pues pusieron el
acento en el rechazo no queremos ese
modelo tan radical insisto porque hay
mucha radicalidad en algunas propuestas
que es normal cuando hay una revolución
de la envergadura el estallido social de
alguna manera la radicalidad se puede
plasmar en un modelo social diferente y
eso la gente todavía no está dispuesta a
aceptarlo Manuel elemento generacional
elementos generacional primero decir que
en cuanto la idea de generación como
grupos detario la votación mostró que la
juventud en su mayoría aplastante bueno
como todos los grupos sociales votaron
por el rechazo Entonces
eso es importante tener en cuenta sin
embargo yo no me apuraría tanto a decir
que la velocidad chilena es conservadora
o es de izquierda o es de derecha sino
Pero yo creo que sí un problema de cómo
se presentaron estos temas por ejemplo
el tema del aborto la interrupción del
embarazo en la introducción del embarazo
no siempre fue ilegal en Chile hubo
causales En algunos momentos Incluso en
tiempos de Dictadura sin embargo creo
que el error fue justamente no tomar en
cuenta lo que se llaman en la política
en Chile el cosismo en el fondo los
problemas reales de la gente que se
llamaba por ejemplo tal vez en vez de
haber enfocado el tema en el aborto en
el cuantas semanas En cuáles casos eso
Tal vez se podría haber presentado como
política pública de salud en el fondo
cómo va a ser el nuevo sistema de salud
artículo 61 no está escrito la palabra
aborto a justamente para No justamente
es un buen punto hay que considerarlo
temas como progresismo aborto ideología
de género que se habla mucho ahora
también cancelación son todos temas que
no han sido pues que no fueron puestos
en el fondo que están en el debate pero
que no estaban en el texto
tenemos que Añadir algo sí Bueno yo
diría que las prioridades prioridades
Perdón del gobierno a lo mejor no son
Exactamente no cuajan exactamente con
ciertas reivindicaciones del octurismo
es decir que hay gente que vive el día a
día y que solo quiere alcanzar el fin de
mes y que para esta gente la
descentralización el feminismo el
plurinacional nacionalismo no es no
forma parte de sus prioridades
es la famosa lucha bueno que nosotros se
ve en chile se ve casi es un debate de
nuestros días como conjugar ecologismo
con justicia social se puede extrapolar
a cualquier país del mundo a cualquier
sociedad no pero ahora cuando lo vamos a
hacer de alguna manera yo pienso que hay
que ser más valientes en sentido y
también optar por posiciones más
radicales Perdón que nos van a llevar
justa sino vamos directo al muro y me
queda muy poco tiempo pero quiero
preguntarles por algún par de temas más
eh de los nuevos nombres del nuevo
gabinete le sorprende alguno le
sorprenden los cambios que ha hecho
Boris lo que sorprende
es el anticomunismo que ha vuelto a
reflotarse en el debate público sobre
todo en algún lado obviamente por la
derecha que es un discurso muy
tradicional en Chile hasta altura porque
está haciendo bastante odioso en el
fondo se están empezando a poner un poco
en duda que el partido comunista
participe de cierta instancias de
gobierno sin tomar en cuenta que es uno
de los partidos de la coalición sin
embargo el resto de los nombres no
sorprende algunos ya se se hablaban se
hablaban así algunas semanas como el de
la nueva ministra del interior el
Carolina toda
sin embargo sí representa un golpe
anímico para cierto sector de de apoyo
del gobierno que es volver a ver caras
30 años cómo se llaman de la antigua
concertación de nuevo en el gobierno
donde medro de fuerzas que sé yo que se
pensaban que eran tal vez más hegemónica
podríamos decir que Boris sale
debilitado de Cómo ven el futuro de
pocos segundos Al contrario estoy muy de
acuerdo en la posición un nombre de
diálogo es un hombre que es muy flexible
y de hecho la prueba está con este
cambio gabinete instala un socialismo
democrático o de nuevo en su gabinete
sobre todo y le da un vuelco a queremos
más experiencia queremos cara nueva y
también queremos caras antiguas y crea
un consensus me quedo sin tiempo para
más ha sido un placer Muchísimas gracias
a los tres y a todos ustedes le
esperamos aquí la próxima semana en
Primera Plana gracias